on va prendre tout de suite la direction
de l'ukraine pour y retrouver notre
correspondant gulliver craag bonjour à
vous gulliver on a vu la situation dans
les différentes zones de combat actuel
et on a appris ce matin qui a affirmé
que les soldats qui s'étaient retirés du
côté de la fameuse usine de dassault ce
talent à marioupol avait en réalité reçu
l'ordre d'arrêter de combattre
oui en fait ils l'avaient dit déjà le 16
mai je pense qu'ils avaient reçu un
autre aujourd'hui danis prokopenko le
commandant du régiment azoff qui est
l'un des formations l'une des formations
militaires ukrainienne qui étaient à
l'intérieur d'un obstacle a confirmé que
cet ordre et l ordre d'arrêter de
combattre et donc de prioritiser
l'évacuation d'abord des civils ensuite
des soldats blessés et puis maintenant
des corps des soldats ukrainien tomber
et ce serait cette opération-là qui
seraient encore en cours en ce moment
c'est pour cela que pas tous les soldats
ukrainiens sont encore sortie d'haze
ostal si je comprends bien c'est parce
qu'ils sont encore en train de sortir
les corps des défunts pour que ces
derniers puissent avoir dans les mots de
prokopenko des funérailles dignes dans
le territoire contrôlé par l'ukraine
mais beaucoup beaucoup d'ambiguïtés
reste encore on ne sait pas quel sera le
sort des soldats qui ont été emmenés
pour la plupart d'entre eux vers la
partie d'ukraine contrôlé par la russie
depuis et 2014 pour une certaine partie
d'entre eux ont réussi à propres dont le
site de la russie l'ukraine bien sûr
espère que ces soldats vont pouvoir être
échangés contre des prisonniers de
guerre russe mais les messages venant de
moscou sont beaucoup plus ambigu sur ce
point des députés de la douma russe
parle de classifier le régiment azoff
comme une organisation terroriste ou
bien de passer une loi qui interdirait
tout échange de prisonniers qui peut
être désigné comme un nazi et on le sait
bien la russie aime beaucoup appelé à
tous les membres du régiment azoff des
nazis ce qui est loin d'être le cas en
réalité même si une certaine partie de
ont effectivement des racines dans le
mouvement néonazi alan gayle gabala pour
la situation du côté de 2 rioufol du
côté du dombass maintenant dans la
région de louhans ce que moscou affirme
ce matin que la conquête de cette région
est donc quasiment achevée
alors les ukrainiennes je pense à dire
est que ce n'est pas achevée encore
puisque les trois plus grandes villes de
la partie de la région de lougansk qui
est encore contrôlée par le cren
severodonetsk roubinet et les sites
chance que sont encore sous contrôle
l'ukrainienne mais comme le disait ce
matin le gouverneur de la région de
luhansk sergei qaïda les attaques de la
russie sur ces localités se sont
intensifiés par un facteur de plusieurs
fois ces derniers 24 heures il a dit que
les douze morts civils cris ont été
officiellement annoncée hier à sévir au
donetsk seulement c'est seulement ce qui
a pu être établi et en réalité comme les
équipes de sauvetage ukrainiens n'ont
pas vraiment accès à une grande partie
de la ville à cause des bombardements
continus le vrai chiffre peut être bien
plus élevé que cela donc de l'aveu des
séries gaiden la situation est très très
très difficile dont la partie de la
région de lougansk est contrôlé par
l'ukraine mais l'ukraine n'a pas encore
admis sa défaite dans cette région les
forces ukrainienne continuent de lutter
et pour le moment ces trois villes clés
restent sous contrôle ukrainienne merci
beaucoup gulliver crack correspondant de
france 24 ans en ukraine pour toutes ces
dernières